so when you first read the script uh the
the current script that ultimately uh
was this movie what was your first take
on it and what was the thing about poric
that struck you the most my first take
was concern
um
[Laughter]
not the answer you're expecting perhaps
but I I had read an earlier Incarnation
about seven years
um before about seven years ago Martin
had sent me an email and he sent Brendan
and Nemo saying this is something I
wrote something I'm thinking of doing
tell me what you think I thought it was
great he says it was [ __ ] he obviously
holds himself to a higher standard than
I do
um I was ready to do that film then
years later you know five years later
this version came and it was the first
couple of pages remain the same
basically the concept that one friend
decided to tell another friend that he
didn't like him anymore and that their
friendship was dead that remained the
same but the rest of the script was
incredibly different
and Martin went from the one that I read
initially being more plot driven and
there was more action scenes and there
was shootouts and to be honest with you
my character was a bit cooler
and wasn't yeah I know I know and what's
the opposite of cool it wasn't as deeply
lonely and he wasn't as he had a
Simplicity to him but he wasn't as
simple as lovely porrick
um is and so when I read it honest to
God I was kind of like oh my God oh my
God oh God it's so I I limped away from
reading it I was ultimately very moved
by it because it is at its core to me a
story about loneliness and about regret
and about community of course and and it
has a certain existential robot at
Center but yeah concern just could I
could I do it and not be dollars
dishwater for an hour and a half was
basically the issue
Martin what was why did you not like the
the one that you sent to Colin seven
years ago the script and and then how
did it evolve from something that was
maybe a little bit more like in Bruges
to something that was much more of a
character study
um uh it it was just the things that I
like about this one just weren't really
there it it focused on it started off
with with the breakup and then just went
to there were outside characters who
came in and um uh it it just become
became plotty and and wasn't about the
relationship anymore um it didn't reach
the emotional depth that this does yeah
not even close because it wasn't about
the two of you I think so so I'd
literally just had forgotten about it
the entire story of scrapped it and
didn't think about it but then I reread
it sort of by accident three years ago
and
um uh and did like the first five pages
which are pretty much the same as as the
first five minutes here but then
everything else is is is new everything
else is just focusing on
the sadness of a breakup really and I
was sort of in a breakupy kind of
situation back then too and just trying
to explore the sadness of that you know
as as deeply sad as those things can be
from both sides you know from you know
in in some ways uh Brendan's character
is in a sad place too probably not quite
as sad as as Collins but um that there's
often something terribly sad about being
in the position where you have to
break up with someone too
um but none of I think the the Artistic
integrity angle was in the original
script too and I think that's kind of
what makes this what it is and did you
were you riding with all four of the of
the principles in mind yeah yeah so
obviously you know I wanted to get Colin
and Brendan back together since since In
Bruges days we'd always stayed in touch
and we did seven psychos together
um but it wasn't like we were phoning
each other up saying when's is going to
happen but it was just lingering
definitely me and Brandon were phone
actually
that's why I do my best writing
um but uh yeah so
um yeah to get the boys back uh it was
always always you know there um but also
it's written for Kerry Condon and Barry
kyogan too
um Kerry I think is amazing in it she we
worked together 20 years ago she was in
one of my stage plays Lieutenant finish
more in the UK as a 19 year old I think
um so see so I've known how brilliant
she's she is as as Colin did a couple of
films with her I think way back then
we've known how good great she is but
it's never quite been
um uh explored so much on on movie she's
done great TV work too but um so that
was written for her to to show exactly
how brilliant she is and she knocked it
out of the park uh and Barry kyogan too
I didn't really know him before but um
he's just heartbreaking and effect in
this I think what is your when you're
working together I think part of the
pull of this movie is that that we don't
know that much about the characters just
the the biographical details of these
and when you're first of all Colin when
you're when you take on a character how
much work do you do on filling in any
backstory that's not there in the script
I'm in Park's backstory it depends it
changes gig to Gig character to
character and I love that we were
dropped in right at the start of this
and I think somehow by doing that
I I'm sure this wasn't your intention
maybe it was but I think Martin bypassed
any kind of prejudice that the audience
could possibly have or could cultivate
as a result of finding out who these
people were or what they're like in
their daily lives we meet these two
humans essentially we all know we're
versions of each other anyway all eight
billion of us were old versions of each
other in Greater lesser degrees so you
kind of meet it with an open unbiased
mind and heart I think and the central
thing then Allegiance May begin to
present itself over the telling of the
story an audience member might find that
they sympathize with poric and then they
might find that maybe pork is being a
little bit too much and he needs to
shush now Parikh shush I'd shush if I
were you shush because it's serious and
because Brandon's character is going
through an awful awful kind of
psychological and emotional time in his
life so I it was never it was never lib
to me you know I love I did a little bit
of backstory but the beautiful thing
about Park was as much backstory as you
needed you get in the first 60 seconds
you see that he was a young man well
young man that's my denial
I'll try that again you see the park is
a middle-aged man defeated who's walking
across the island on the way to meet his
friend and he looks like he might have
just won the lottery you know he's so
happy and content and connected and he's
looking up the sky and the clouds and
the formation of them he's looking at
the tall grass and listening to the
waves gently crash against you know the
shoreline and he just connected pure and
connected simple doesn't want much for
life not ambitious not an ideologue
nothing and he comes over the crest and
that's all you need to know and then the
rest of it for me was the disintegration
of that joy and the loss of that
innocence over the next 90 minutes so
that poryg ended up at the end somebody
who believing that there is a place for
violence in the world and that it
doesn't even need to be justified and
that man is essentially cruel and dark
and he can't find any of the joy that he
once had in his life and they're both
cursed they're both cursed and I
wouldn't even blame column in the end of
the film you know they're both cursed by
the confusions that can can plague us
just by virtue of Being Human and
wondering what our purpose is and how
how our lives can be justified
in Martin do you have full biographical
details in your head when you're writing
does it does it come to you do you
create that and so obviously
absolutely none literally I've just
whatever's on the page is all I've got
you know
um I I don't really do that backstory uh
all the all the actors I've worked with
kind of know that it's kind I think it's
a good thing or it could be a really
really lazy thing but um it's I kind of
think it's for the actor to come come
with or be free to come with that sort
of stuff and you're not you're not big
on outlines and things like that or
maybe you are sometimes but my
understanding is with this one you
really started and discovered it as you
went along yeah and that's that's been
the same with all the plays and all the
all the screenplays too and never
outline and never know where it's going
never know the ending usually just have
one or two characters and start from
there and this is
Jenny Jenny and Minnie Jenny yeah donkey
and a horse how can we get it financed
Colin and Brenda
um but uh but but no because you don't
know because I don't know what's going
to happen when Brendan comes into the
pub and makes a threat that surprised me
you know as much as it did anyone else
because I didn't know he was going to do
right I love that idea of you with a pen
and paper or whatever your pen and paper
yeah yeah paper it would be his pen and
paper and writing column comes into the
pub and literally not known and then
going ah and they loved that idea that's
so lovely yeah it is but and then it for
then it gives you sort of the next 30
minutes of sure of the film because it's
you know how are we going to deal with
that but there's a joy not to know that
kind of stuff is there a quickening
after that moment after yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you're just trying to keep up
after that that's cool I am I saw Sam
Rockwell in the lobby
where is he oh
where was that hey poopy baby hi Leslie
yeah did you he said he had a question
and I promise
no
talented obviously for Martin
oh yeah I'll tell you that
um
my favorite craft service snack
it's pretty easy at this stage no
seriously what um how was the rehearsal
process for this was it was it useful
was it a sort of like uh let's get on
with it or no it was I I
um
honestly I had an awful amount of fear
around the tunnel I I really did and I
you know we all got in it was amazing
because
I feel there was a kind of a Confluence
of things that were happening there is
what do you call yourself London Irish
British not to delete call yourself
anything yeah London Irish so anyway
we'll just say at least 50 right but by
genealogical bloodline he's an Irish man
and he grew up in London et cetera but
we don't claim ownership but we're very
proud of them at home as well and
Brendan we love at home I've done okay
and I'm an Irishman and so we were all
going home to tell a very Irish story in
an incredibly Irish place so I can say
such thing and not sound like an
interloper and the west coast and you
know inishmore and apple Island as he
said so there was this sense of coming
together we rehearsed in the Druid
theater rehearsal space where Martin put
on the beauty queen of lenan all those
years where they rehearsed and worked
chopped your first yeah I mean that was
a huge kind of Full Circle so the first
day we were in there for a table read
and we were all really nervous and
really excited excited and then
yeah it was trying to get to how you
know yourself man sometimes the way
something when you read it you may love
it but it may seem so heightened that
it's Way Beyond your reach and the
process and rehearsal for me on this was
trying to just
bridge the gap close the gap between
how heightened and how painful and how
funny sometimes you want to get ignured
to the comedy so that you're playing it
you're never playing I mean you're never
playing it for Laughs anyway but it's so
funny the stuff that he writes and
it's like this process in rehearsal
where the humor gets less and less the
more you look at it and the pain gets
more and more and more and then you go
and you put it in front of a camera and
the audience sees and the humor is still
there but only because you're actually
tending to the other stuff and so I I
loved I mean by the time we were
finished the rehearsal I was chomping at
the bit and ready to go but um but loved
that part of the process really did
I want to thank you both for the movie I
want to congratulate you on the movie
thank you everybody thanks everyone
thanks everyone for coming thank you
[Applause]